la fête des amoureux qui fait le bonheur
des fleuristes mais pas seulement
choses vues lors de ce 14 février
l'occasion de se dire je t'aime de mille
manières nicolas lemarignier pour
déclarer sa flamme à l'élu de son coeur
il y à des méthodes testées et
approuvées depuis des générations mais
venise cela finit par manquer
d'originalité
alors comment s'y prend à paris la
solution cette année c'était les
panneaux municipaux des je t'aime les je
t'aime mon canard lancé sous les yeux de
milliers de parisiens
c'est sûr ça impression ça fait super
plaisir
c'est très touchant ça fait surtout ceux
là surprise
le fait de le voir en grand et ça fait
très très plaisir pour les timides qui
skie sur les sommets enneigés
il y à bourg-saint-maurice une messagère
un peu particulière être de descente une
inconnue vous apporte des fleurs c'est
ça l'effet saint valentin
on admire acteur en 2003 la barre était
placée très haut
il reste une année pour trouver encore
mieux ou au moins trouver l'âme soeur